[Music]
we used to China's growing power in
almost every field from trade to
geopolitics and now it's the turn of
science on January the 3rd China landed
a rover on the far side of the moon it
was the first country to do so and it
signaled China's soaring ambitions in
science space is just one area in which
they're pouring many millions of dollars
into research genomeics quantum
communications materials in all these
areas China is putting a huge effort
into becoming a leader and it's about 10
or 15 years before China becomes a
scientific superpower China's going to
all these efforts because it knows that
a strong science base is essential if it
is to be a first-class economic and
military power but in the rush to get
ahead Chinese scientists sometimes take
ethical shortcuts scientific theft and
copying and fraud is rampant and last
year heard yanqui an associate professor
from shenzhen genetically modified to
embryos without proper regard to their
welfare when they were born or indeed
the welfare of any children they might
go on to have and at a time of growing
competition between the United States
and China the West is worried what this
growing scientific Chinese power really
means these worries are real it's not
just a question of Chinese weapons but
also how they might use science to
oppress their own people for instance
already China is using artificial
intelligence to have real-time facial
recognition of its people what is it to
have a scientific superpower wrapped up
in a one-party dictatorship
Chinese research has a lot to offer the
world in save battery technology or the
cures to diseases or fundamental
discoveries into for instance dark
matter and the nature of science itself
may help make China a better scientific
actor for one thing science is
collaborative if you try and cut
yourself off as a nation
you'll only hinder your own scientific
progress if it wants to be cutting-edge
China will benefit from working with
other countries and that means in order
to collaborate and have access its
scientists will have an incentive to
follow the rules but the most
interesting question of all is where the
science might end up changing China
president si Jinping is betting that he
can have leading-edge science at the
same time as the Communist Party
increases its stranglehold on Chinese
society but is he right about that
of course not all scientists are
Democrats but science itself involves
critical thinking questioning Authority
empiricism making judgments about the
world and all of these things threaten
autocrats who survive by controlling a
way that people think so President Xi
could face a tough choice if he wants
his scientists to be cutting-edge he may
have to give them the freedom and risk
the consequences in that sense he's
running the biggest experiment of all
you